donc
la Commission recommande au Conseil
européen premièrement de donner à
l'Ukraine une perspective européenne et
deuxièmement de lui accorder le statut
de candidat ceci bien entendu à
condition que le pays procède un certain
nombre d'autres réformes importantes
c'est un sérieux coup d'accélérateur qui
a été donné à la candidature ukrainienne
oui tout à fait c'est à dire ça n'est
pas une adhésion Express que demander
monsieur zellenski le président
remporte néanmoins une victoire très
forte et très symbolique parce que en
fait le statut de candidat lui a été
accordé très très vite en raison de la
guerre en Ukraine beaucoup plus vite que
c'est l'usage et même à vrai dire c'est
un calendrier un peu inversé d'habitude
on demande aux gens de faire énormément
de réformes et de se mettre à niveau et
puis on leur accorde voilà le statut de
candidat là on a vu que ça a pris
effectivement quelques semaines alors la
commission valide le dossier mais c'est
sa sortie d'une feuille de route très
précise pour essayer justement dans ce
pays qui est en guerre où il y a une
sorte de désorganisation quand même de
l'État et bien de remettre en ordre
l'État de droit par anticipation en tout
cas en tout cas d'avoir une réserve une
réserve tout de même puisque il y a un
certain nombre de pays qui notent que et
bien on ne remplit pas les critères et
puis on ne suit pas le trajet habituel
pour ce pays certes cette candidature ou
plus exactement l'entrée dans l'Union
européenne garantit un certain un
certain nombre de choses dont la défense
il y a de défense le 40 l'article 42,7
mais évidemment il ne s'applique que
quand vous êtes à l'intérieur de l'UE
donc c'est une première candidature en
tout cas d'un pays en guerre c'est clair
et on va vite avoir les yeux rivés donc
sur ce Conseil européen des 23 et 24
juin est-ce que la candidature
ukrainienne peut passer alors ça va être
compliqué parce que d'abord elle a été
très poussée portée à bras à bout de
bras part les pays de des pays baltes
les pays comme la Pologne les pays de
l'Est et puis maintenant ils ont été
rejoints par vous l'avez dit hier grande
réunion à Kiev avec Emmanuel Macron
Mario Draghi avec le président roumain
et et Olaf schols bien sûr qui donc en
donnait un coup d'envoi nous nous sommes
pour et donc ça met la pression maximum
sur les 27 pour le prochain conseil
simplement c'est vrai que de l'autre
côté il y a des Pays-Bas de l'Autriche
le Danemark la Finlande qui sont des
pays très rigoristes sur l'état de droit
qui veulent véritablement une lutte
effective anticorruption et qui ont noté
que quand dans le club européen quand on
a élargi très très vite à l'est et bien
certains sont restés sur le chemin de la
lutte anticorruption pouvant être très
réservés et puis il y a la Moldavie qui
a obtenu au passage la même chose et
puis il y a les Balkans qui se disent
ben nous on est laissés dans une encore
plus dans l'antichambre du club européen
on nous a oublié parce qu'on a pas de
guerre chez nous et donc ça c'est aussi
un problème qui va falloir régler
l'heure du prochain conseil qui sera
aussi dédié au balcon la situation
exceptionnelle réponse exceptionnelle
merci beaucoup Caroline pour votre
analyse